if you were roaming websites for
something to view a foreman opinion no
matter what you do come in join me join
me join me join me or is it right back
and watch my video we're gonna watch the
movie leave yours try mini-din the best
I've ever seen in my life
give a tip if you could come on out
Jesus Boyd or you could maybe tell my
friend just bury but I live in a wood
that seriously I wouldn't dock you
looking poison fatality start by killing
me then just what that word means my
vocab ain't that good my rhyming also
kinda sucks but at least I star in
believe you come to me I'll tell it
straight Citizen Kane he second-rate
everything who drop us by my office and
the north side bend to follow your nose
to the horrifying stench your head might
feel queasy and your nostrils might
bleed but at least we'll watch some /
review come on give a guy a break will
ya can I change Japan I'm just doing
fast
the blade is hopeless put it this side
of the garbage can Jack and Jill
it was a great ironic twist showing what
happens when an actor just doesn't care
about his career anymore and is it me or
did his twin sister really local a thank
you come on it goes I swear I'm not
gonna use the money for alcohol or drugs
I'm just gonna use it to give it to
another person who's going to give me
alcohol or drugs so please don't tell
the cops see you
noticed me there's only so many times I
can plead insanity it's hard to get
through it but it's the one must do it
history / video house he's gone got
thrown away don't live in sight and
ashtray to their species I guess there's
no more song for me to sing about I'll
take this opportunity to scream and
shout JJ JJ JJ JJ JJ please give me some
cheese for a review
who wrote this crappy music anyway